hello everyone and welcome back to the
superbed rapid and Blitz tournament
currently being played in Poland after
the three days of Rapid young shisht of
Duda is in the lead and now we have uh
two days of Blitz we will have nine
rounds of uh Blitz chess per day and
this is a very nice game from round four
I believe uh let me just check I don't
want to trick you guys I'm pretty sure
it's round four no it's round five
actually a good thing I checked uh of
the of the blitz section and it's Magnus
Carlsen versus killshevchenko and as the
title suggests uh it's uh
um very nicely played by both sides but
uh one slight mistake is exploited uh to
to the maximum so let's see what
happened here Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with Ponte E4 uh we
have Pawn to C5 shivchenko goes for the
uh Sicilian Defense Knight F3 Knight the
C6 and now not the straightaway open
Sicilian first Knight to C3 this is the
closed traditional line uh G6 and now
Pawn to D4 very quickly we will
transpose in into the accelerated dragon
with Knight captures we have now
transposed into the accelerated Dragon
of the Sicilian Defense Bishop to G7
Bishop to E3 and not Knight to F6 and
here uh many moves are possible uh top
moves are Bishop to C4 also Bishop to
eight you can be played very popular
respawn to F3 uh some other moves have
also been played like you you could just
maybe capture capture and pawn to E5
this has also been played and it's all
perfectly fine for both white and black
here Magnus tries Knight the B5 it's
actually the fifth a knight to B3 it's
the fifth most um a popular continuation
and he wants to confuse KIRO as much as
possible so here Pawn to D6 we have Pawn
to F3 a pretty standard move against the
the dragon uh castles and now Queen to
D2 preparing the trade of the dark
Square Bishop Sevilla Bishop to H6 uh
with Bishop to E6 and now Queen side
castles and here uh Knight the E5 you
could also just continue development
with some like Rook to C8 or queen to C7
or a6b5 and so on who goes for Knight to
E5 it's again a standard maneuver in the
dragon you're fighting for that C4
Square uh so you will attack the queen
and um bishop and then uh Magnus will
have to give up his light Square Bishop
so here uh there are a couple of moves
that have been played here like Bishop
th6 uh also uh Pawn to H4 is a known but
Magnus plays the prophylactic King to B1
and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so KIRO
replies with uh Rook the theater again a
very standard stuffed Ponte H for and
pawn to H5 nowadays uh whenever you play
against the dragon as soon as H4 hits
the board H5 will follow it's just no no
one allows anything here H5 is the must
play move with Bishop D two now
preparing G4 and pawn to A6 and here
uh the problem with the media the G4 is
that the move we discussed at some point
Knight to C4 will be played to give you
an example if G4 H characters AF
captures and not even Bishop captures on
G4 Bishop capture is now the bishop no
longer controls the C4 square and Knight
does come to C4 and now you will lose
the dark Square Bishop which is a very
important piece let's say queen goes
here captures an E3 Queen captures and
now you gobble up the bishop here you
attack the queen and once the queen
moves uh there are even all sorts of
Rook captures and C3 ideas but of course
you are expecting this when you play uh
when you play against the Sicilian Rook
captures on C3 is a pretty standard idea
now you can't capture with the queen
because of Knight to F2 so you're gonna
capture with the pawn now Knight goes
back to F6 and black has more than
enough compensation for the sacrifice
exchange if anything black is better
here so instead after this A6 move we
have Bishop to D4 and now the bishop is
no longer a Target if Knight the C4 is
played plus the bishop will be very
strong Here and Now Magnus is preparing
Pawn to G4 and okay nothing spectacular
Happening Here Queen to C7 G4 by Magnus
and now age captures on G4 and now
Magnus plays Pawn to F4 and this is a
very delicate situation that kiril is in
because you have to play play a very
very precise moves here one of the ideas
is Rook f2d8 just a nice developing move
and you say okay if you capture my
knight I'm gonna capture back here and
now your Bishop will
uh fall on the next move you could also
remove the Knight not there you can move
the Knight to D7 that's perfectly fine
if now F5 you can play Bishop to C4 this
is all perfectly and perfectly fine you
could play Knight to C4 right away and
go after the the queen here then we uh
go after the the Knight hero or we play
Queen to C1 uh the move that you
shouldn't play is Knight to C6 this is a
very problematic and it allows the
magnets to really take advantage of the
uh poor peace placement of uh of Kira so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best way to take the
most out of the position uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
uh well uh very simple simple but very
clear idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures on F6 just like that remove the
defender of the G4 Pawn uh and then
after Bishop captures an F6 just Knight
the D5 you attack the queen and the
bishop on F6 and it would be too
dangerous to allow
um the knights to remain on D5 it's just
that the Knight on D5 against the dragon
is a monster Knight and next H5 is
coming if black does not react so of
course you have to capture Bishop
captures and D5 was played ecamp person
D5 attacking the Knight and now Knight
the D4 and now uh Magnus gobbles up the
G4 pawn bishop captures and G4 and now
the problem is that you also will have
Bishop to E6 at some point not right
away of course you want to play H5
captors here and then captors back will
be impossible due to Bishop to E6 so
it's just a very powerful square plus
also the rook and C8 is hanging so this
is really really bad night characters on
B3 is played magnus's Queen is now
hanging but it doesn't matter a captures
on B3 now comes spawn to A5 and here
Ponte H5 Magnus goes for the attack we
have Ponte A4 KIRO replies in the in the
same fashion and now H captures on G6 a
captures on B3 we have C capture some B3
and here Rook to A8 trying to get some
sort of an attack going uh but Magnus
just played a queen to H2 here and he
was in this position unmove 25 that KIRO
serchenko resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
really let's play the game by World
rapid champion and former World
classical champion and the world Blitz
Champion Magnus Carlsen uh just
exploiting the the you know slightest of
inaccuracies uh very nicely in the Blitz
game here you resign as there is no
defense against Queen H7 Checkmate
whatever you do there's nothing here you
could try to prolong it a little bit or
maybe create some threads here giving up
some pieces here but even the playing
King capture some B2 and black is Adam
also really
I have nothing to fear here so after uh
uh Queen to H2 of course he resigned and
again we we come back to the old Bobby
Fisher saying I don't know if it's
actually a saying but it's something
that Bobby Fischer said that why
um he does not play the dragon because
it's too easy to to crush the dragon or
to slay the dragon he said you just play
G4 G5 H5 uh you you open up the the king
set and Checkmate the black king which
is uh which is kind of the exact recipe
that Magnus used here to win this game
uh but again it all came down to this
moment he found a very precise Bishop to
D4 and then after all of this uh well
Knight the C6 the slight inaccuracy then
he just uh uh you know uh made the most
out of the position as I'm sure you guys
did as well during the pause the video
moment uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it the first game that
we are covering from the blitz section
if you have any of your favorites do
your suggestion I will go over it and if
it's a nice game we will show it for
everyone else they enjoy
yeah once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank David Kimura
golfsoftware.com uh Paul hinamund Gary
Shaw and ravishing reptiles YouTube for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day